E
THAT ROE VERSUS WADE WAS SETTLED
PRECEDENT.
>> APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
>>> ALSO WITH US TO DISCUSS THE
DECISION, ELIZABETH WARREN OF
MASSACHUSETTS.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US.
YOU SAID DEMOCRATS HAVE TOOLS
THE FIGHT BACK.
HOW EFFECTIVE DO YOU THINK THOSE
MEASURES ARE GOING TO BE?
>> THEY WILL BE JUST AS
EFFECTIVE AS THEY NEED TO BE.
I AM SPITTING MAD OVER THIS.
WE HAVE SIX EXTREMIST JUSTICES
ON THE UNITED STATES SUPREME
COURT WHO HAVE DECIDED THAT
THEIR MORAL AND RELIGIOUS VULS
SHOULD BE IMPOSED ON THE REST OF
AMERICA.
THIS IS NOT WHAT AMERICA WANTS.
IN A DEMOCRACY ON THIS ISSUE,
THE SUPREME COURT DOES NOT GET
THE LAST WORD.
THE PEOPLE DO.
WE ARE GOING TO FIGHT BACK.
WE'VE GOT TOOLS.
WE'RE GOING TO USE THEM AND IN
NOVEMBER, WE'RE GOING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ELECT ENOUGH PEOPLE
WHO BELIEVE IN THAT DEMOCRACY
THAT WE CAN PASS ROE VERSUS THE
WADE AND MAKE IT THE LAW OF THE
LAND AGAIN.
ONLY THIS TIME WE'LL DO IT BY
STATUTE AND ENFORCE IT.
>> RESPECTFULLY, THIS ISSUE, AS
IMPORTANT AS IT IS TO A NUMBER
OF DEMOCRATS, YOU'RE A PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF THAT, HAS NEVER BEEN
THE RALLYING TOOL FOR DEMOCRATS
THAT IT HAS BEEN FOR
REPUBLICANS.
WHAT'S GOING TO CHANGE BETWEEN
NOW AND NOVEMBER?
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT WHY THAT HAS
BEEN SO.
ABOUT 70% OF AMERICANS WANT TO
SEE ROE VERSUS WADE MAINTAINED
AS THE LAW OF THE LAND OPINION
ONE SUPREME COURT NOMINEE AFTER
ANOTHER STOOD IN FRONT OF
CONGRESS, RAISED THEIR RIGHT
HAND AND SAID NOT INTERFERING
WITH SETTLED LAW.
I BELIEVE IN THE RULE OF LAW AND
SAID ROE VERSUS WADE IS SETTLED
LAW.
THAT MEANS THAT A HUGE
PROPORTION OF THE POPULATION IN
AMERICA BELIEVED THIS IS NOT A
HUGE ISSUE.
IT'S PROTECTED.
WE'RE GOING TO BE FINE.
THOSE OF US WHO WERE RINGING THE
ALARM BELLS WERE TOLD DON'T
WORRY ABOUT THIS.
NOBODY GOING TO OVER TURN ROE
VERSUS WADE.
NOW, A SMALL MINORITY HAS
FINALLY GOTTEN THE VOTES.
THE REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE WORKED
FOR DECADES KNOWING THAT THEY
COULD NEVER PASS THIS THROUGH
CONGRESS, THEY COULD NEVER GET
IT THROUGH A STATE BALLOT
INITIATIVE, THEY WORKED ON
GETTING IT THROUGH GETTING
EXTREMISTS JUDGES THROUGH.
JUDGES WHO PROMISED TO FOLLOW
THE LAW BUT WINK, WINK, NOD, NOD
WERE CLEARED IN ORDER TO GET
WHERE THEY GOT TODAY.
THAT IS TO SAY THAT THEY'RE
RELIGIOUS AND PERSONAL VIEWS
WILL BE FORCED ON THE REST OF
AMERICA AND THEY WILL USE THE
GOVERNMENT IN ORDER TO ENFORCE
IT.
NOTICE, JUST YESTERDAY THERE
SAME SET OF EXTREMISTS SAID, OH,
IT IS NOT POSSIBLE TO LET THE
STATE GOVERNMENTS GET ENGAGED ON
THE QUESTION OF GUNS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE FEDERAL
PROTECTION FOR GUNS.
THE REST OF US ARE READY TO
RALLY BACK AND SAY IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE FEDERAL
PROTECTION FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
PREGNANT.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE
INDIVIDUALS RIGHTS, INDIVIDUALS
NEEDS.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE BE ABLE
TO MAKE THESE DECISIONS FOR
OURSELVES AND NOT HAVE A
GOVERNMENT THAT STEPS IN TO DO
THAT BECAUSE SIX EXTREMISTS ON
THE SUPREME COURT WANT THE
GOVERNMENT TO ENFORCE THEIR
RELIGIOUS BELIEFS.
>> ON A CUP OF THOSE POINTS
HERE, QUICKLY.
THE FACT THIS NOW GOES BACK TO
STATES, YOUR HOME STATE OF
MASSACHUSETTS, THE HIGHEST COURT
IS UPHOLDSING THE RIGHT TO AN
ABORTION.
PASSING LAWS TO PROTECT ABORTION
RIGHTS.
WE'RE SEEING MORE OF THAT IN A
NUMBER OF BLUER STATES.
THE REALITY OF WHAT CAN HAPPEN,
YOU TRIED THE LEGISLATIVE ROUTE
NOT TO LONG AGO.
THAT FAILED.
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER ISN'T GOING
TO REENSTATE THIS AND IF IT DID,
IT COULD BE OVER TURNED BY
ANOTHER PRESIDENT.
REALISTICALLY SPEAKING WHEN YOU
SAY THERE'S WORK TO BE DONE,
LEGISLATIVELY AND YOU WANT TO
SEE SOMETHING ON A FEDERAL
LEVEL, WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE?
>> IT LOOKS LIKE GETTING TWO
MORE DEMOCRATS IN THE UNITED
STATES SENATE WHO ARE WILLING TO
SUPPORT BOTH FILIBUSTER REFORM
AND MAKING ROE VERSUS WADE THE
LAW OF THE LAND.
IT MEANS HANGING ONTO THE HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES AND PASSING
ROE INTO LAW.
THAT'S WHAT NOVEMBER WILL BE ALL
ABOUT.
RECOGNIZE WE DON'T HAVE TO WAIT
UNTIL NOVEMBER.
THERE ARE THINGS WE CAN DO RIGHT
NOW.
WE CAN HELP WITH CONTRIBUTIONS
AND VOLUNTEERING.
WE ALSO CALL ON THE
ADMINISTRATION.
SENATOR PATTY MURRAY AND I LED A
LETTER CALLING ON PRESIDENT
BIDEN TO USE THE TOOLS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO HIM RIGHT NOW.
HE CAN MAKE MEDICATED ABORTION
MORE WIDELY AVAILABLE.
HE CAN HELP WITH MONEY AND TIME
OFF FOR PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE ACROSS STATE LINES.
HE CAN CONSIDER USING FEDERAL
LANDS AS A PLACE WHERE WE CAN
SET UP ABORTION CLINICS AND
PEOPLE CAN GO THERE WHO NEED
ACCESS TO ABORTION.
WE ARE NOT WITHOUT ACTIONS WE
CAN TAKE.
WE NEED TO HAVE HOPE BUT WE NEED
TO HANG ON NO THIS ANGER BECAUSE
WE USE THAT ANGER TO FUEL
CHANGE.
>> WE'RE OUT OF TIME.
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM THE
PRESIDENT ADD 12:30.
HAS PRESIDENT BIDEN BEEN A
STRONG ENOUGH ADVOCATE?
YES OR NO?
>> WHAT MATTERS IS WHERE HE IS
TODAY.
THIS IS THE MOMENT IN FRONT OF
US.
IT'S NOT WHAT MATTERED WHEN
NOBODY THOUGHT ROE WAS GOING TO
BE THROWN OUT.
THE PRESIDENT NEEDS TO PICK UP
EVERY TOOL AVAILABLE TO HIM AND
USE IT TO PROTECT ACCESS TO
ABORTION.
USE IT TO PROTECT THE INDIVIDUAL
RIGHTS OF THOIZ WHO ARE COUNTI